thank you yes sir today we have a lot of
special guests I'm joined in the studio
by Shannon Bailey welcome Shannon thank
you for having me you are the chief
Creator at the World Chess Hall of Fame
and you have a brand new exhibit which
is called sound moves where chess meets
music yeah tell us a little bit about
this new exhibition yeah so I co-curated
the exhibition with Bradley Bailey who's
my husband and he is a kind of a he's a
professor at St Louis University in our
history but he does a lot of research on
chess and art and Marcel Duchamp so he's
done other projects here at the hall of
fame and he's a big fan of music and and
if you know anything about the Hall of
Fame we are also huge fans of music so
it seemed like it was an appropriate
time to mix those two together and do an
exhibition
well actually I find this combination
very interesting because for example in
Paris we have a lot of exhibits where
there are a lot of paintings associated
with music so what is the connection
between chess and music there are so
many we probably could have done like
four or five shows on different aspects
of Chess and music but we have just some
things that are just fun where like
musicians love chess and they've
Incorporated uh chess into their music
videos or their album covers or their
music posters we look at things like you
know time in oven smyslav who were
fantastic musicians and fantastic chess
players and that they could have
excelled at either one of those Arenas
we kind of open up the show in a really
exciting way where you walk in and you
see Katy Perry's 2015 halftime show with
her Dark Horse video which is this
beautiful chess piece with a stage and
costumes that are chess pieces and we
have two of those at actual costumes
from the Super Bowl from the designer
Marina toyvena we have musical
instruments Jacqueline piadagorski who's
in the U.S Chess Hall of Fame her
bassoon and then we have Guido
vanderver's chess piano which is an
actual chessboard that has all of the
piano percussive elements underneath so
you can play music by playing a chess
game
well Shannon I've been thinking uh you
worked on this exhibit and you've seen
it as a visitor so what is your personal
best my favorite oh my gosh that's
really hard
um
I it's it's not it when you walk in and
you see the Katy Perry exhibit that's
really fun but I love the album covers
you know I grew up in the 70s and 80s
when everybody was had their album you
know their vinyl Collections and now all
of that's coming back so I kind of like
seeing those I like seeing the the
photographic elements that we have in
the show where you have like David Bowie
playing chess or Frank Sinatra you know
playing chess with Walter Brown and you
know different bands that are out there
playing chess or you know using it for
for publicity shots it's fun well so
this really sets the mood then yeah I
know the players uh well they have their
competition in the World Chess Hall of
Fame yes how how well do you feel about
it yeah the last couple of major
tournaments have been at the hall of
fame and I love that I love seeing the
players in the building I think it's
great that they're playing in our third
floor Gallery which is where we kind of
show off our chess history shows and
we've got our Hall of Fame interactive
screens that have the US and the World
Chess Hall of Fame inductees in there
and I just think it's really great
because you know that a lot of these
players will be in the Hall of Fame
someday so it's it's great to have that
energy in the building and I know that
our visitors and our staff really love
it too
thank you yes sir jump into the
conversation yeah first of all uh
welcome Shannon hi yes sir it's great to
have you on the show as always I'm very
very excited because of the Abba chess
coming to the muni
before you became the curator would were
you even aware that ABBA did an album
called chess by Tim Rice well I love
music and I definitely knew the song One
Night in Bangkok
U.S
um I don't I my parents listened to Abba
when I was growing up but I don't think
I understood that they wrote a lot of
the music for Chess the musical and I'm
glad that Yasser brought that up because
we have some artifacts in the exhibition
related to several of the variations of
Chess the musical and in St Louis this
summer uh July 5th through the 11th at
the muni is Chess the musical The London
version of it will be played here and so
it's been a really great opportunity to
collaborate with an outstanding St Louis
institution and um you know we're always
looking for ways to get people
interested in chess that might not be
originally so we do things you know
through our exhibitions things like
music if you like music come on in and
you know you might like chess too so
it's it all works out well for us
thank you Shannon I think that's a great
chance for all of us to see the musical
chess on stage yeah so well sees the
opportunity yes absolutely absolutely
awesome awesome looking forward to it
thank you Shannon and for all you do at
the World Chess Hall of Fame uh really
really big appreciation yes thank you
and I'm